hey Doug Walker here no Rob this time so
sorry
he didn't make it to the screening but
yeah I am just going to talk about
Deadpool before I talk about the movie I
should talk about what I know about
Deadpool which actually isn't much ah
every time I go to a con just like a
million Deadpool so I know he's a really
popular character I know he's aware he's
a fictional character so there's a lot
of fourth-wall jokes I know he's like an
action hero who can't lie or kind of an
antihero and he does a lot of comedy
because he knows he's a character and he
like can get shot and either doesn't
feel the pain or heals up or something
like that II and even though I'm still
not entirely sure Eddie has a thing for
chimichangas that's about all I know so
in terms of like does this represent the
source material whatever I'm only
guessing but I'm gonna come at just as a
movie critic here and as a movie like
this goes it's fine
it's got some laughs it's got some good
action uh and that's about it um I think
there's a lot of hype around this movie
and I'm it in no way disappoints uh I
think it gives you exactly what you
think you're going to get and that's it
um and the audience I saw with was very
very excited and very happy to see it
and laughing at every single joke and
getting invested when it got dramatic
and yeah I saw saw it as all those that
was fun that was enjoyable and I never
need to see it again
it's way it's one of those movies where
I kind of thought maybe the humor was
gonna be up even a little bit more of
that make sense like kind of like Hot
Fuzz uh you know our worlds end where
there's just so many jokes being thrown
at you but it's and they're good jokes
that they're good in the moment jokes
and they're good fourth wall breaking
jokes um but yeah I think the one
weakness it has I say is in my bum
review too is that when it needs to be a
regular movie like when needs to do the
drum
attic stuf uh it's not bad by any means
but it's very standard this is very much
the kind of movie you see where those
movies you see advertised where they
always take place at night and it's lit
by street lights and someone's wearing a
hat like this it's really muscle-bound
and get revenge because somebody did him
wrong or kidnapped his girl or something
like that or kill this dog you know some
weird crap like that as just them going
around with guns and shooting guys
except there's a few superheroes attempt
and fourth-wall jokes now even though
many superheroes but weird ones that
they pick too and I don't know this ties
into the comic because we have Colossus
from x-men and some other one I don't
recognize that she had some sort of long
elaborate name I did but they were both
really cool honestly this is I feel like
this is kind of the best x-men movie
we've gotten yet because when Colossus
comes out he's Russian he looks like
Colossus he's the size he has the
personalities can do just they're very
nice and very you know just almost
gentlemanly and almost very simple and
that that kinda felt like what Colossus
was you know he's not just a big muscle
guy who's a narc and help you and that's
it you know it's he's Russian he's all
these things and there's a scene where
he's just watching TV and the the teen
girl that can blow up I forget her name
um not Jubilee different one much cooler
one um you know they're just watching TV
angles oh we should go help and they
just go get the Blackbird and fly out
actor felt like yeah that's x-men that's
comic books and this is very much a
comic book movie um like I said with a
lot of these uh breaking the fourth wall
jokes and so I like that and I like a
lot of the like I said a lot of humor
there's a there's a romance between Ryan
Reynolds and and the other lead I don't
know her name sorry uh but they have
legitimately good chemistry they're both
kind of nutty and make these one-liners
but she's not just a carbon copy of him
either you know
which is nice geez our own unique
character of the villains pretty
standard the side characters the help is
pretty standard it's funny cuz this
movie actually opens up it has the
funniest opening credits uh where the
credits are just they don't say who the
actual people are they just sort of say
their roles like starring you know a
douchebag who's paid too much or the
comic relief or a CGI character like
they're saying all this stuff you see in
a million movies and you're gonna see in
this movie too so it's I don't know
maybe maybe that's kind of like the
secret genius of is that it actually is
just an unbelievably standard movie that
just has such a good sense of humor that
it's kind of like a baby you kind of
take it um but the humor doesn't go
through all all the way through and I
don't think that's what Deadpool was
from what I understand I don't think it
was 100% comedy it is still a comic book
film it is still about revenge it is
still about kicking ass and a lot of
cool stunts and powers and stuff and
then people looking really you know
pained and angsty and going oh you know
all of that stuff so that's all in there
um and yeah I guess maybe I thought was
gonna be a little bit more unique in
that sense I mean I hear Deadpool one of
his big comedic things is that he
constantly compares himself to other
characters like spider-man or Wolverine
because he can heal up in his fight man
cuz it kinda looks like spider-man uh so
maybe that's kind of a thing maybe they
know they're kind of stealing from all
these other things and they're kind of
having fun with it um but if it if it
was it was taking it so pretty seriously
but I don't know I guess something like
dark man does something kind of similar
doesn't have fourth-wall jokes but it's
this very obvious standard plot that
you've seen in comic books a million
times but it gives it its own unique
spin so yeah I think when the sir came
around to being like this dramatic film
the part where you're supposed to really
care with the exception of the romance
which surprisingly I really bought the
chemistry uh I thought everything else
was just kind of standard like I've seen
it a lot
there's even one or two times I was
kinda like okay where's a key look at a
camera again but um but it's good um I I
guess I found maybe I get something a
little bigger or even more jokes flying
out at you but I'll be honest I'm
probably really spoiled with what I
thought this was gonna be because like I
said I mean I am thinking can like the
Cornetto trilogy or Hot Fuzz or
something like that what it's just gonna
be a ton of jokes um and there are a
fair amount of jokes and very clever
jokes uh there's the opening credits I
guess they're very funny there's a great
scene where he spells out the bad guy's
name I won't give it away um some really
funny one-liners um so yeah it it's fun
it's a fun shoot-'em-up action flick
with some funny lines uh but ton of in
jokes as you'd imagine
and most of oh my god there's one or two
like he meets a guy who's like his best
friend I think called Bob or something
like that the audience doesn't Wow like
Bambi went huh and these guys are from
me you were trying to tell me I said no
no no silly it's like his best friend
from on okay so one always gets him in
trouble he's one down like I said okay
okay what is missed you you got it
you're the people that this is made for
and that's what matters and that's why I
feel like I feel like the crab has saw
this really really liked it really got
into it and really laughed at like every
joke and I fee and they applauded at the
end they waited like nobody left before
the credits stopped like everybody stay
because they knew they're going to be
something at the end uh so I think that
that's the kind of people this was made
for it was made for fans it kind of
feels like a fan movie I took my wife to
go see who you know she liked it fine
but there's a lot of times where she's
like what's that I don't know that what
does that mean what is that you know
there's references to Wolverine Origins
and Stan Lee cameo and stuff so there's
all this stuff that unless you know
Marvel and comic-book movies and stuff
like that you're not gonna get this is
very much it feels like a fan film but
kind of the right kind of fan film um so
yeah it's
one uh probably as anti-climactic of
review as you can get I don't love it
but I thought it was you know at those
miles an enjoyable film uh so not much
else I can say outside of that I could
do a spoiler corner cuz there's really
nothing to spoil I mean like what you
guess is going to happen it's exactly
what happens but again that's not the
kind of movie it is it's there for the
jokes it's here to get this incredibly
popular character on the big screen and
it seems like it's done well at all the
cosplayers I see had cons and the way
they act they all act like this asshole
so I'm assuming this is what the
character is like um so yeah if if
you're looking for some good laughs and
some fun action and just cg superheroes
jumping around punching stuff this is
great it's a lot of fun and it's and
it's gory and there's you know it's
raunchy it definitely earns its our
rating so um yeah that's about it taking
for what's worth and I will see you
later
take care